I will order my government to deny entry
to all Communists and all marxists wow
wow
quite an idea
those who come to and join our country
must love our country we want them to
love our country we don't want them when
they want to destroy our country welcome
to America we want to destroy your
country thank you very much so we're
going to keep foreign Christian hating
Communists marxists and socialists out
of America all right so you get the idea
keep communist marxists and socialists
out of the United States also equating
being a socialist to hating America
there's many socialists who like America
in the same way that there's many people
who think gun laws should be more
permissive who like America just because
you want something to be different
doesn't mean you hate America but what
Trump is proposing is almost certainly
against the law and impossible from a
practical perspective